have you noticed Tyler Galpin has a lot
in common with Hans from Frozen and can
you guess the reason why we said Bianca
Barclay should play a second princess in
our fantasy movie this is our
reimagining of Wednesday as a Disney
movie as a Disney princess Wednesday
reminds us a lot of Belle she's
completely obsessed with books and
willing to accept things even if they
look a little strange her trusty
sidekick would have to be thing of
course you're in dying loyalty to me
which might just be one of the sickest
pets that we can think of she's true to
herself and she's no Damsel in Distress
waiting around to be saved making her a
lot more like this new age of Disney
Princesses than you would think plus she
comes with her own castle in the form of
Nevermore Academy when it comes to
design she'd have the big eyes and bangs
of Cinderella with her hair obviously
dyed black her princess gown would
probably be something like the one that
she wore during her iconic dance
sequence but of course no Disney
princess would be complete without her
friends Bianca Barclay would start out
our movie as a bit of an antagonist she
wouldn't be the main villain of course
that role is going to be filled by our
next entry of course but we can see a
bit of rivalry turned friendship Dynamic
similar to what we see between
Tinkerbell and Vidya I work up in the
sky and you work down in a ditch Bianca
is a siren and right away that makes us
think of the sea monsters from Luca can
anyone else see this getting a meeting
between two World story Brewing from
Disney I was just curious when it comes
to Bianca's personality she shows a
surprising amount of similarities to
Princess Tiana with her hard-working
dedication to whatever task that's set
before her seriously coach when am I
gonna get some real competition it's
from Tiana that we're borrowing the
basis of our design too imagine her with
Bianca's gorgeous buzz cut and blue
green eyes and that's basically what
we're imagining here in some ways Bianca
can almost be considered the movie's
secondary princess similar to what we
saw with Elsa and Anna in Frozen again
like in Frozen we're picturing Two
Princes in our movie and Tyler Galvin
has to be one of them like what we saw
with Hans we'd think that Tyler was
Charming handsome and perfect for our
main princess Wednesday when we first
meet him but as the movie went on we'd
find out that he's been doing the
bidding of the wicked witch Laurel Gates
all along and if you'd like to avoid
getting in trouble with Laurel we'd
recommend taking this moment to click on
that subscribe button before we move on
for Laurel we imagine a design that
would be sort of similar to what we saw
with Bellwether from zootopia will be
unstoppable just you know more human and
less cheap when it comes to Tyler we're
going right back to that good old Hans
comparison except we're giving him
Tyler's curly brown mappa hair now that
still leaves a spot for a prince open in
our movie and we can only think of one
person who'd serve that part perfectly
Xavier Thorpe would make the perfect
Prince la like we saw with Kristoff our
leading princess would probably have
reason to be suspicious of him at first
didn't your parents ever warn you about
strangers yes they did but his enduring
loyalty would eventually win her over
now it's hard to say which Princess the
movie would have Xavier wind up with in
the end since Xavier and Bianca have
history together the movie could choose
to have them reconcile in a big dramatic
moment that brings the people of the
land and sea closer together but since
Wednesday is our main character and
she's got to be hurting after Tyler's
betrayal we could also see Disney going
for the feel-good ending and having her
move on with Xavier let us know down in
the comment section which ending you
could see Disney going for over the
other when it comes to Xavier's design
we're imagining something similar to
Camilo from Encanto though maybe with
straighter hair but when Xavier winds up
with Wednesday or not we know she'll
always have her trusty Roommate by her
side Enid Sinclair is a true friend we
can see her in a role similar to
Charlotte from Prince test in the Frog
where her bubbly personality serves as
the perfect bolster for our more serious
princess
she did definitely share Charlotte's
love for the color pink too with her
dresses reflecting that every time she's
on screen Enid probably wouldn't be
featured too much in the main storyline
which would probably focus more around
the friendship between Wednesday and
Bianca but she'd still make for perfect
comedic relief OMG you look perfect only
thing where are your whiskers Enid just
has this endless enthusiasm about her
and it kind of reminds us of Anna from
Frozen between their Bright Smiles and
Rosy disposition we can see a bit of
physical resemblance between Anna and
Enid too if he were to cut Anna's hair
to her shoulders and dye it blonde or
pink that is but a cast of young people
in a Disney movie wouldn't be complete
without a mentor to guide them we all
know that Wednesday is pretty capable of
getting things done her own way but a
bit of guidance isn't necessarily a bad
thing we can see Larissa Weems playing
the role of Wednesday's older and wiser
Mentor in a similar style to the way
that moana's grandmother helps her find
herself
[Music]
we can see her taking a back seat to a
lot of the action like moana's
grandmother does but whenever she's on
screen she's the smartest person in the
movie Just Like Gwendolyn Christy
Larissa's design would have to be pretty
physically imposing plus with her heavy
makeup we can see her looking a lot like
a more humanized version of The Fabulous
sea witch Ursula with her hair a little
longer of course when it comes to
dresses she'd always be wearing
something glamorous and classic just
like Larissa's Hitchcock inspired
outfits on the show from princesses to
villains and even Sidekicks we have it
all planned out now we just need someone
at Disney to sign off on it do you agree
with our fantasy of Wednesday as a
Disney movie or would you have done
anything differently there's plenty of
room to get creative here so make sure
to write your suggestions in the comment
section down below
[Music]